[MUSIC PLAYING]
CLEMENS MEWALD: My
name is Clemens.
I'm the product lead
for TensorFlow Extended,
the end-to-end machine
learning platform
that we built for TensorFlow.
And we have a lot of
exciting announcements,
so let's jump right in.
A lot of you may be
familiar with this graph.
We published this
in a paper in 2017.
And the main point that I
usually make on this graph
is that there's more to machine
learning than just the training
part.
In the middle,
the trainer piece,
that's where you train
your machinery model.
But if you want to do machine
learning in production
reliably and in a
robust way, you actually
need all of these
other components
before and after, and in
parallel, to the training
algorithm.
And often I hear, sometimes
from researchers, well,
I really only do research.
I only care about training
the machine learning model
and I don't really need all of
these upstream and downstream
things.
But what I would argue
is that research often
leads to production.
And what we want to
avoid is researchers
having to re-implement
their hard work,
in a model that they've
built, when they want to put
the model into production.
That's actually one
of the main reasons
why we open sourced
TensorFlow because we really
wanted the research community to
build the models in a framework
that we can then use and
actually move into production.
A second comment
that I hear often
is, well, I only have
a very small data set
that fits in a single machine.
And all of these tools
are built to scale up
to hundreds of machines.
And I don't really need
all of these heavy tools.
But what we've seen time
and time again at Google
is that small data today
becomes large data tomorrow.
And there's really
no reason why you
would have to re-implement
your entire stack just
because your data set grew.
So we really want to
make sure that you
can use the same tools
early on in your journey
so that the tools can actually
grow with you and your product,
with the data, so that you
can scale the exact same code
to hundreds of machines.
So we've built TensorFlow
Extended as a platform
at Google, and it has
had a profound impact
to how we do machine
learning and production
and into becoming
an AI-first company.
So TFX really powers some of
our most important Alphabet
companies.
Of course, Google is just one
of the Alphabet companies.
So TFX is used at six
different Alphabet companies.
And within Google,
it's really used
with all of the major products.
And also, all of
the products that
don't have billions of users
[INAUDIBLE] this slide.
And I've said before
that we really
want to make TFX
available to all of you
because we've seen
the profound impact it
has had on our business.
And we're really
excited to see what
you can do with the same
tools in your companies.
So a year ago we talked
about the libraries
that we had open sourced
at that point in time.
So we talked about TensorFlow
Transform, the training
libraries, Estimators and Keras,
TensorFlow Model Analysis,
and TensorFlow Serving.
And I made the point that, back
then, as today, all of these
are just libraries.
So they're low-level
libraries that you still
have to use independently
and stitch together
to actually make work and
train for your own use cases.
Later that year, we added
TensorFlow Data Validation.
So that made the picture
a little more complete.
But we're still far away
from actually being done yet.
However, it was extremely
valuable to release
these libraries at
that point in time
because some of our
most important partners
externally has also had a
profound impact with some
of these libraries.
So we've just heard from
our friends at Airbnb.
They use TensorFlow
Serving in that case study
that they mentioned.
Our friends at Twitter just
published this fascinating blog
post of how they used
TensorFlow to rank tweets
on their home timeline.
And they've used TensorFlow
Model Analysis to analyze
that model on different
segments of the data
and used TensorFlow Hub to share
some of the word embeddings
that they've used
for these models.
So coming back to this picture.
For those of you who've
seen my talk last year,
I promised everyone
that there will be more.
Because, again, this is
only the partial platform.
It's far away from actually
being an end-to-end platform.
It's just a set of libraries.
So today, for the
very first time,
we're actually sharing
the horizontal layers
that integrate all
of these libraries
into one end-to-end platform,
into one end-to-end product,
which is called
TensorFlow Extended.
But first, we have to
build components out
of these libraries.
So at the top of this slide,
you see in orange, the libraries
that we've shared in the past.
And then in blue, you
see the components
that we've built
from these libraries.
So one observation to be
made here is that, of course,
libraries are very low
level and very flexible.
So with a single library, we can
build many different components
that are part of machine
learning pipeline.
So in the example of
TensorFlow Data Validation,
we used the same
library to build
three different components.
And I will go into detail on
each one of these components
later.
So what makes a component?
A component is no
longer just a library.
It's a packaged
binary or container
that can be run as
part of a pipeline.
It has well-defined
inputs and outputs.
In the case of Model
Validation, it's
the last validated model,
a new candidate model,
and the validation outcome.
And that's a
well-defined interface
of each one of these components.
It has a well-defined
configuration.
And, most importantly, it's
one configuration model
for the entire pipeline.
So you configure a TFX
pipeline end to end.
And some of you
may have noticed,
because Model Validation needs
the last validated model,
it actually needs some context.
It needs to know what was the
last model that was validated.
So we need to add a metadata
store that actually provides
this context, that
keeps a record of all
of the previous runs so that
some of these more advanced
capabilities can be enabled.
So how does this
context get created?
Of course, in this case, the
trainer produces new models.
Model Validator knows about
the last validated model
and the new candidate model.
And then downstream
from the Validator,
we take that new candidate model
and the validation outcome.
And if the validation
outcome is positive,
we push the model to
the serving system.
If it's negative, we don't.
Because usually we
don't want to push
a model that's worse
than our previous model
into our serving system.
So the Metadata Store is new.
So let's discuss
why we need this
and what the
Metadata Store does.
First, when most people
talk about machine learning
workflows and
pipelines, they really
think about task dependency.
They think there's one component
and when that's finished,
there's another
component that runs.
However, all of you who
actually do machine learning
in production know that we
actually need data dependency,
because all of these components
consume artifacts and create
artifacts.
And as the example of Model
Validation has showed,
it's incredibly important
to actually know
these dependencies.
So we need a system that's
both task and data aware so
that each component
has a history of all
of the previous runs and knows
about all of the artifacts.
So what's in this
Metadata Store?
Most importantly,
type definitions
of artifacts and the properties.
So in our case, for TFX,
it contains the definition
of all of the artifacts that
are being consumed and produced
by our components and
all of their properties.
And it's an extensible
type system,
so you can add new
types of artifacts,
if you add new components.
And you can add new
properties to these artifacts,
if you need to track
more properties of those.
Secondly, we keep a record
of all of the execution
of the components.
And with that
execution, we store
all of the input artifacts
that went into the execution,
all of the output artifacts
that were produced,
and all of the
runtime configuration
of this component.
And, again, this is extensible.
So if you want to track things
like the code snapshot that
was used to produce
that component,
you can store it in the
Metadata Store, as well.
So, putting these
things together
allows us to do something
we call lineage tracking
across all executions.
Because if you think
about it, if you
know every execution, all of its
inputs and all of its outputs,
you can piece together a story
of how an artifact was created.
So we can actually, by
looking at an artifact,
say what were all of
the upstream executions
and artifacts that went into
producing this artifact,
and what were all of
the downstream runs
and downstream artifacts
that were produced using
that artifact as an input?
Now, that's an extremely
powerful capability,
so let me talk you through
some of the examples of what
this enables.
The first one is a pretty
straightforward one.
Let's say I want to
list all of the training
runs that I've done in the past.
So in this case, I am
interested in the trainer
and I want to see all
of the training runs
that were recorded.
In this case, I had
two training runs.
And I see all of the properties
of these training runs.
This is pretty straightforward,
yet nothing new to see here.
However, I just
spoke about lineage.
We can visualize that lineage
and all this information
that we have.
The first comment on
this slide to make
is we're working on a better UI.
This is really just for
demonstration purposes.
But if you look at the end of
this graph to the right side,
you see the model expert path.
This is the specific instance
of a model that was created.
And as you can see,
we see that the model
was created by the trainer.
And the trainer
created this model
by consuming a Schema,
Transform and Examples.
And, again, these are
specific instances.
So the IDs there are
not just numbering,
they're Schema of ID
number four and Transform
of ID number five.
And for each one
of those artifacts,
we also see how they
were created upstream.
And this allows us to do this
lineage tracking and going
forward and backward
in our artifacts.
The narrative I used was
walking back from the model but,
similarly, you could look
at your training data
and say, what were all of the
artifacts that were produced
using that training data?
This slide shows a visualization
of the data distribution
that went into our model.
Now, at first
glance, this may not
be something earth shattering
because we've done this before.
We can compute statistics
and we can visualize them.
But if we look at
the code snippet,
we're not referring
data or statistics.
We're referring to a model.
So we say for this
specific model,
show me the distribution of data
that the model was trained on.
And we can do this
because we have a track
record of all of the data
and the statistics that
went into this model.
We can do a similar thing
in the other direction
of saying for a specific model,
show me the sliced metrics that
were produced downstream by
TensorFlow Model Analysis,
and we can get
this visualization.
Again, just by
looking at a model
and not specifically pointing to
the output of TensorFlow Model
Analysis.
Of course, we know all of
the models that were trained
and where all of
the checkpoints lie
so we can start TensorBoard
and point to some
of our historic runs.
So you can actually
look at the TensorBoard
for all of the models that
you've trained in the past.
Because we have a track
record of all of the models
that you've trained, we can
launch TensorBoard and point it
to two different directories.
So you can actually compare two
models in the same TensorBoard
instance.
So this is really model tracking
and experiment comparison
after the fact.
And we enable this by keeping
a track record of all of this.
And, if we have
multiple models, you
can also look at the
data distribution
for multiple models.
So this usually helps
with debugging a model.
If you train the same model
twice, or on different data,
and it behaves
differently, sometimes it
can pay off to look at whether
the data distribution has
changed between the
two different ones.
And it's hard to
see in this graph,
but here we're
actually overlaying
two distributions
of the statistics
for one model and the other.
And you would see if
there's a considerable drift
between those two.
So all of these are enabled
by this lineage tracking
that I just mentioned.
Another set of use cases is
visualizing previous runs
over time.
So if you train the same model
over time, over new data,
we can give you a time series
graph of all of the evaluation
metrics over time,
and you can see
if your model improves
or gets worse over time
as you retrain them.
Another very powerful use
case is carrying over state
from previous models.
Because we know that you've
trained the model in the past,
we can do something
we call warm starting.
So we can
re-initialize the model
with weights from
a previous run.
And sometimes we want to
re-initialize the entire model
or maybe just an embedding.
And in this way, we
can continue training
from where we left off
with a new data set.
And another very powerful
application of this
is being able to reuse
previously computed outputs.
A very common workflow is
to iterate on the model
and basically iterate on
your model architecture.
Now, if you have a
pipeline that ingests data,
applies transformations
to your data,
and then you train a model--
every time you make a
small change to your model,
you don't want to recompute
everything upstream.
There's no reason why you would
have to re-ingest your data,
re-compute the transform just
because you changed something
in your model.
Because we have a track record
of all of the previous steps,
we can make a decision of
saying your data hasn't changed,
your transform code
hasn't changed,
so we will reuse the artifacts
that were produced upstream.
And you can just iterate much,
much faster on your model.
So this improves
iteration speeds,
and it also saves compute
because you're not
re-computing things that you've
already computed in the past.
So now, we've talked about
components quite a bit.
Now how do we actually
orchestrate TFX pipelines?
First, every component
has something we
call a driver and a publisher.
The driver's responsibility
is to basically retrieve state
from the Metadata
Store to inform
what work needs to be done.
So in the example
of Model Validation,
the driver looks into
the Metadata Store
to find the last
validated model,
because that's the
model that we need
to compare with the new model.
The publisher then basically
keeps the record of everything
that went into this component,
everything that was produced,
and all of the
runtime configuration,
so that we can do
that linear tracking
that I mentioned earlier.
And in between
sits the executor.
And the executor is blissfully
unaware of all of this metadata
stuff because it's
extremely important for us
both to make that piece
relatively simple.
Because if you want to
change the code in one
of these components, if you want
to change the training code,
you shouldn't have to worry
about drivers and publishers.
You should just have to
worry about the executor.
And it also makes
it much, much easier
to write new components
for the system.
And then we have one
shared configuration model
that sits on top that configures
end-to-end TFX pipelines.
And let's just take a look
at what that looks like.
As you can see, this
is a Python DSL.
And, from top to
bottom, you see that it
has an object for each
one of these components.
From ExampleGen,
StatisticsGen, and so on.
The trainer component,
you can see, basically
receives its configuration,
says that your inputs
come from the transferred
output and the schema that
was inferred.
And let's just see what's
inside of that trainer.
And that's really
just TensorFlow code.
So in this case, as you can
see, we just use an estimator.
And we use to estimator
train and evaluate method
to actually train this model.
And it takes an estimator.
And we just use one of our peak
end estimators, in this case.
So this is a wide and deep
model that you can just
instantiate and return.
But what's important
to highlight here
is that we don't have an
opinion on what this code looks
like, it's just TensorFlow.
So anything that produces
a safe model as an output
is fair game.
You can use a Keras model that
produces the inference graph
or, if you choose to,
you can go lower level
and use some of the
lower-level APIs in TensorFlow.
As long as it produces a safe
model in the right format
that it can be used
TensorFlow Serving,
or the [? eval graph ?] that
can be used in TensorFlow Model
Analysis, you can read any type
of TensorFlow code you want.
So, if you've noticed,
we still haven't
talked about orchestration.
So we now have a configuration
system, we have components,
and we have a metadata store.
And I know what some of you
may be thinking right now.
Is he going to announce a
new orchestration system?
And the good news is no--
at least not today.
Instead, we talked to a lot
of our users, to a lot of you,
and unsurprisingly found out--
whoops.
Can we go back one slide?
Yup.
Unsurprisingly found
out that there's
a significant installed
base of orchestration
systems in your companies.
We just heard from Airbnb.
Of course, they
developed Airflow.
And there's a lot of
companies that use Kubeflow
And there's a number of
other orchestration systems.
So we made a deliberate
choice to support
any number of
orchestration systems
because we don't want
to make you adopt
a different
orchestration system just
to orchestrate TFX pipelines.
So the installed base
was reason number one.
Reason number two
is we really want
you to extend TFX pipelines.
What we publish is really
just our opinionated version
of what a TFX
pipeline looks like
and the components
that we use at Google.
But we want to make
it easier for you
to add new components before
and after and in parallel
to customize the pipeline
to your own use cases.
And all of these
orchestration systems
are really made to be able to
express arbitrary workflows.
And if you're already familiar
with one of those orchestration
systems, you should be able
to use them for your use case.
So here we show you
two examples of what
that looks like with Airflow
and Kubeflow pipelines.
So on the left you see that
same TFX pipeline configured
that is executed on Airflow.
And there on my example we
use this for a small data
set so we can iterate on
it fast on a local machine.
So in the Chicago taxicab
example we use 10,000 records.
And on the right side, you
see the exact same pipeline
executed on Kubeflow
pipelines, on Google Cloud
so that you can take advantage
of Cloud Dataflow and Cloud ML
Engine and scale it up to
the 100 million [INAUDIBLE]
in that data set.
What's important here is
it's the same configuration,
it's the same components, so
we run the same components
in both environments,
and you can
choose how you want
to orchestrate them
in your own favorite
orchestration system.
So this is what this looks
like if it's put together.
TFX goes all the way
from your raw data
to your deployment environment.
We discussed a shared
configuration model
at the top, the metadata system
that keeps track of all the
runs no matter how
you orchestrate
those components,
and then two ways
that we published of
how to orchestrate them
with Airflow and with
Kubeflow pipelines.
But, as mentioned, you can
choose to orchestrate a TFX
pipeline in any way you want.
All of this is available now.
So you can go on GitHub, on
github.com/tensorflow/tfx
to check out our code and
see our new user guide
on tensorflow.org/tfx.
And I also want to point
out that tomorrow we
have a workshop
where you can get
hands-on experience with
TensorFlow Extended,
from 12:00 to 2:00 PM.
And there's no prerequisites.
You don't even have to
bring your own laptop.
So with this, we're going to
jump into an end-to-end example
of how to actually go
through the entire workflow
with the Chicago taxicab
data set And just
to set some context.
So the Chicago taxi
data set is a record
of cab rides in Chicago
for some period of time.
And it contains everything
that you would expect.
It contains when the trip
started, when they ended,
where they started
and where they ended,
how much was paid for
it, and how it was paid.
Now, some of these features
need some transformation,
so latitude and longitude
features need to be bucketized.
Usually it's a bad
idea to do math
with geographical coordinates.
So we bucketize them and treat
them as categorical features.
Vocab features, which are
strings, need to be integerized
and some of the Dense Float
features need to be normalized.
We feed them into a
wide and deep model.
So, the Dense features we feed
into the deep part of the model
and all of the others
we use in the wide part.
And then the label that
we're trying to predict
is a Boolean, which
is if the tip is
larger than 20% of the fare.
So really what
we're doing is we're
building a high tip predictor.
So just in case if there's any
cab drivers in the audience
or listening online,
come find me later
and I can help you
set this up for you.
I think it would be
really beneficial to you
if you could predict if a cab
ride gives a high tip or not.
So let's jump right in.
And we start with data
validation and transformation.
So the first part of the TFX
pipeline is ingesting data,
validating that
data-- if it's OK--
and then transforming
it such that it can
be fed into a TensorFlow graph.
So we start with ExampleGen. And
the ExampleGen component really
just ingests data into
it a TFX pipeline.
So it takes this
input, your raw data.
We ship by default capabilities
for CSV and TF Records.
But that's of course
extensible as we
can ingest any type of
data into these pipelines.
What's important is
that, after this step,
the data is in a well-defined
place where we can find it--
in a well-defined
format because all
of our downstream components
standardize on that format.
And it's split between
training and eval.
So you've seen the configuration
of all of these components
before.
It's very minimal configuration
in most of the cases.
Next, to move onto data
analysis and validation.
And I think a lot of you
have a good intuition why
that is important.
Because, of course,
machine learning is just
the process of taking
data and learning models
that predict some
field in your data.
And you're also aware that
if you feed garbage in,
you get garbage out.
This will be no hope in a
good machine learning model
if the data wrong, or if the
data have errors in them.
And this is even reinforced if
you have continuous pipelines
that train on data that
was produced by a bad model
and you're just reinforcing
the same problem.
So first, what I would argue
is that data understanding
is absolutely critical
for model understanding.
There's no hope in
understanding why
a model is mis-predicting
something if you don't
understand what the
data looked like
and if the data was OK that was
actually fed into the model.
And the question you
might ask as a cab
driver is why are my trip
predictions bad in the morning
hours?
And for all of these questions
that I'm highlighting here,
I'm going to try to
answer them with the tools
that we have available
in TFX later.
So I will come back
to these questions.
Next, we really would like
you to treat your data
as your treat code.
There's a lot of care
taken with code these days.
It's peer reviewed, it's checked
into shared repositories,
it's version
controlled, and so on.
And data really needs
to be a first class
citizens in these systems.
And with this question,
what are our expected
values from our
payment types, that's
really a question about
the schema of your data.
And what we would argue
is that the schema
needs to be treated
with the same care
as you treat your code.
And catching errors early
is absolutely critical.
Because I'm sure,
as all of you know,
errors propagate
through the system.
If your data are not OK, then
everything else downstream
goes wrong as well.
And these errors are extremely
hard to correct for or fix
if you catch them relatively
late in the process.
So really catching those
problems as early as possible
is absolutely critical.
So in the taxicab example,
you would ask a question
like is this new company that
I have in my data set a typo
or is it actually a
real company which
is a natural evolution
of my data set?
So let's see if we can answer
some of these questions
with the tools we
have available,
starting with Statistics.
So the StatisticsGen
component takes in your data,
computes statistics.
The data can be
training, eval data,
it can also be serving logs--
in which case, you can look at
the skew between your training
and your serving data.
And the statistics really
capture the shape of your data.
And the visualization
components we
have draw your
attention to things
that need your attention, such
as if a feature is missing
most of the times, it's
actually highlighted in red.
The configuration for this
component is minimal, as well.
And let me zoom into some
of these visualizations.
And one of the questions
that I posed earlier
was why are my tip predictions
bad in the morning hours?
So one thing you could do
is look at your data set
and see that for trip
start hour, in the morning
hours between 2:00
AM and 6:00 AM,
you just don't have much
data because there's not
that many taxi
trips at that time.
And not having a lot of data
in a specific area of your data
can mean that your model is not
robust, or has higher variance.
And this could lead
to worse predictions.
Next, you move on the
SchemaGen. SchemaGen
takes this input, the
output of StatisticsGen,
and it infers schema for you.
In the case of the
chicago taxicab example,
there's very few
features, so you
could handwrite that schema.
Although, it would be hard
to handwrite what you expect
the string values to look like.
But if you have
thousands of features,
it's hard to actually
handwrite that expectation.
So we infer that schema for
you the first time we run.
And the schema really represent
what you expect from your data,
and what good data
looks like, and what
values your string features
can take on, and so on.
Again, very minimal
configuration.
And the question
that we can answer,
now, is what are expected
values for payment types?
And if you look here
at the very bottom,
you see the field
payment type can
take on cash, credit, card
dispute, no charge, key card,
and unknown.
So that's the
expectation of my data
that's expressed in my schema.
And now the next
time I run this,
and this field takes
on a different value,
I will get an anomaly--
which comes from the
ExampleValidator.
The ExampleValidator takes
the statistics and the schema
as an input and produces
an anomaly report.
Now, that anomaly
report basically
tells you if your data
are missing features,
if they have the wrong valency,
if your distributions have
shifted for some
of these features.
And it's important to
highlight that the anomalies
report is human readable.
So you can look at it and
understand what's going on.
But it's also machine readable.
So you can automatically
make decisions
based on the
anomalies and decide
not to train a model if you
have anomalies in your data.
So the ExampleValidator just
takes this input, statistics,
and the schema.
And let me zoom into one
of these anomaly reports.
Here you can see that the
field company has taken
on unexpected string values.
That just means that these
string values weren't
there in your schema before.
And that can be a natural
evolution of your data.
The first time you
run this, maybe
you just didn't see any trips
from those taxi companies.
And by looking at it, you can
say, well, all of these look
like they're normal
taxicab companies.
So you can update your
schema with this expectation.
Or if you saw a lot of
scrambled text in here,
you would know that there's
a problem in your data
that you would
have to go and fix.
Moving on, we actually
get to Transform.
And let me just recap the
types of transformations
that we want to do.
I've led them here in red--
in blue, sorry.
So we want to bucketize
the longitude and latitude
features.
We want to convert the
strings to ints, which
is also calling integerizing.
And for the Dense features, we
want to actually normalize them
to a mean of zero and a
standard deviation of one.
Now, all of these
transformations
require you to do a
full pass of your data
to compute some statistics.
To bucketize, you
need to figure out
the boundaries of the buckets.
To do a string to
integer, you need
to see all of the string values
that show up in your data.
And to scale to a
Z-score, you need
to compute the mean and
the standard deviation.
Now, this is exactly what we
built TensorFlow Transform for.
TensorFlow Transform
allows you to express
a pre-processing
function of your data
that contains some of these
transformations that require
a full pass of your data.
And it will then automatically
run a data processing graph
to compute those statistics.
So in this case, you
can see the orange boxes
are statistics that we require.
So for minimalization,
we require a mean
and the standard deviation.
And what TensorFlow
Transform does
is it has a utility function
that says scale to Z-score.
And it will then create a
data processing graph for you
that computes the mean
and the standard deviation
of your data,
return the results,
and inject them as constants
into your transformation graph.
So now that graph
is a hermetic graph
that contains all
of the information
that you need to actually
apply your transformations.
And that graph can then
be used in training
and in serving,
guaranteeing that there's
no drift between them.
This basically
eliminates the chances
of training serving
skew by applying
the same transformations.
And at serving time, we just
need to fit in the raw data,
and all the transformations are
done as part of the TensorFlow
graph.
So how does that look
like in the TFX Pipeline?
The Transform component
takes in data, schema--
the schema allows us to
parse the data more easily--
and code.
In this case, this is the
user-provided pre-processing
function.
And it produces the Transform
graph, which I just mentioned,
which is a hermetic
graph that applies
the transformations,
that gets attached
to your training and
your serving graph.
And it optionally can
materialize the Transform data.
And that's a performance
optimization that sometimes you
need when you want to feed
hardware accelerators really
fast, it can sometimes
pay off to materialize
some transformations
before your training step.
So in this case, the
configuration of the component
takes in a module file.
That's just the file
where you configure
your pre-processing function.
And in this code
snippet, the actual code
is not that important.
But what I want
to highlight is--
the last line in
this code snippet
is how we transform our label.
Because, of course, the label
is a logic expression of saying,
is the tip greater
than 20% of my fare?
And the reason why I
want to highlight this
is because you don't need
analyze phases for all
of your transformations.
So in cases where you
don't need analysis phases,
the transformation is just
a regular TensorFlow graph
that transforms the features.
However, to scale something to
Z-score, to integerize strings,
and to bucketize a
feature, you definitely
need analysis phases, and that's
what Transform helps you with.
So this is the user code
that you would write.
And TF Transform would create
a data processing graph
and return the results
and the transform graph
that you need to apply
these transformations.
So now that we've
done with all of this,
we still haven't trained our
machine learning model yet,
right?
But we've made sure that
we know that our data is
in a place where we can find it.
We know it's in a format
that we can understand.
We know it's split
between training and eval.
We know that our data are good
because we validated them.
And we know that we're applying
transforms consistently
between training and serving.
Which brings us to
the training step.
And this is where the magic
happens, or so they say.
But, actually, it's not because
the training step in TFX
is really just the TensorFlow
graph and the TensorFlow
training step.
And the training component takes
in the output of Transform,
as mentioned, which
is the Transform
graph and, optionally, the
materialized data, a schema,
and the training code
that you provide.
And it creates, as
output, TensorFlow models.
And those models are in
the safe model format,
which is the standard
serialized model
format in TensorFlow, which
you've heard quite a bit
about this morning.
And in this case, actually,
we produce two of them.
One is the inference
graph, which
is used by TensorFlow
Serving, and another one
is the eval graph,
which contains
the metrics and the
necessary annotations
to perform TensorFlow
Model Analysis.
And so this is the configuration
that you've seen earlier.
And, again, that the trainer
takes in a module file.
And the code that's actually
in that module file, again,
I'm just going to show
you the same slide
again just to reiterate the
point, is just TensorFlow.
So, in this case, it's the
train and evaluate method
from estimators and a
[? canned ?] estimator
that has been returned here.
But again, just to
make sure you're
aware of this, any
TensorFlow quote here
that produces the safe model in
the right format is fair game.
So all of this
works really well.
So with this, we've now
trained the TensorFlow model.
And now I'm going to hand
it off to my colleague,
Christina, who's going to
talk about model evaluation
and analysis.
[MUSIC PLAYING]